bonsoir mesdames et messieurs ici
patrice roy depuis 2 1 et 2 mois
l'équipe de philippe couillard dirige le
québec je vous propose ce soir une
émission spéciale interactive en direct
avec le premier ministre
quelle belle victoire quelle fierté ce
soir cent cinquante mille emplois ce
n'était pas une promesse c'est une
sérieuse budget équilibré pas eu de
l'austérité je tiens aujourd'hui informé
n'a lui présenter mes excuses à
l'innovation et des d'amalgamé bien la
copie d'un genou et tu as mal choisi de
se bâtir est encore à venir jeudi de
l'annoncé
ce dernier propose le projet de
transport le plus important des 50
dernières années au québec
juste une semaine je suis si je marque
en vain des triplés biomotik jamboree
que j'allais pour une fois si cette
avancée
match québec dgeq tu l'as dans un
milliard de dollars américains en quête
de diallo gourmand md cseries et tripoli
cours alors une iniquité
monsieur le premier ministre bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur roy c'est assez
impressionnant quand voici en accéléré
quand même deux ans il ya deux mois
est ce que vous vous êtes satisfait de
votre premier début demande
je crois qu'on accomplit bien notre
mandat bien sûr il ya toujours des
choses qu'on doit et qu'on peut faire
mieux mais il ya beaucoup de bonnes
nouvelles pour le québec récemment et ce
qu'on avait promis de faire au québec où
on est en train de le faire à plusieurs
égards parce que 68 vous avez eu dernier
sondage 68 % de gens au québec qui se
disent insatisfaits il ya pour quelque
chose comme un bris de confiance que la
politique travers ce qu'on fait notre
politique on traverse des périodes
semblables ce qui est très important
c'est de dire aux québécois pourquoi de
solliciter leur confiance en 2014 est ce
qu'on est en train de faire pour
accomplir ce mandant l'avait dit quoi on
avait dit qu'on va équilibrer le budget
pour avoir des marges de manoeuvre
retrouver la confiance des investisseurs
c'est en train d'arriver on va voir des
images pour l'éducation on le fait on
veut des marches pour la santé également
et pour le développement économique pour
la nouvelle économie du 21e siècle
on est en train d'aller dans cette
direction là les résultats apparaissent
il faut être persistant il faut savoir
ce qu'on fait il faut pas en cours de
route perdre les québécois certains
cours en europe air liquide y en a pas
mais la meilleure façon de ne pas les
perdre cela rappelé que je viens de vous
dire est qu'il est budgétaire finances
publiques bien gérer pour les services
publics et pour l'économie
on en parle depuis quelques jours de
cette émission-là ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont déjà envoyé des questions on va
parler de plusieurs sujets question
difficile question directe me joindre et
si monsieur le premier ministre
tout ce que je dis aux gens c'est que
oui questions dures allez-y vous pouvez
nous les envoyer on ne on ne met pas de
côté les questions dures ce qu'on met de
côté ses les commentaires injurieux
hargneux
on n'en veut pas et carole aoun bonsoir
à vous bon sang parlera pas
rappelons aux gens comment faire pour
nous rejoindre voilà pour les gens à la
maison ou ailleurs qu'il nous écoute à
la télévision traditionnelle ou encore
sur le téléphone la tablette voici
comment nous joindre par courriel
patrice trois arobases red hot radio
canada.ca encore sur facebook sur la
page radio canada informations ou
d'ailleurs l'émission spéciale est
diffusé en direct donc via facebook live
est finalement sur twitter patrice roy
tj
ou encore en utilisant le mot clic
direct pm donc qu'on attend les
questions du public
très bien du coup hier j'ai parlé de
deux périodes difficiles
on a beaucoup parlé d'austérité au
québec chez nous mais pas le mot lomé
excusez moi si je n'aime pas c'est que
ce n'est pas exact c'est que quand on
parle d'austérité ont fait appel aux
exemples qu'on a vu en europe où il ya
eu des coupes massives dans les budgets
des ministères
je répète on n'a pas diminué aucun
budget du ministère on les a fait croire
beaucoup moins nobles nous rapidement
c'est vrai pour rétablir l'équilibré
mais on est à des années lumière de ce
qui était le cas en grèce
amadio terre et en espagne bien sûr il
avait raison mais de moins faire
augmenter un budget du ministère par
rapport à l'inflation par rapport aux
coûts de système entre guillemets ça
correspond à une compression ce si on
gère bien on peut épargner ça mais je
voudrais juste rappeler une chose c'est
que ça a duré un an et demi deux ans au
maximum
il est tout à fait correct pour une
société pour un gouvernement d'ajuster
ses finances de cette façon là d'autres
sociétés leur fait l'ontario notre
voisin l'a fait de façon encore plus
rigoureux très bien alors on a
maintenant l'équilibré pour l'économie
la santé l'éducation
vous avez donc décidé de compression de
d'éliminer certains s'organisent comme
les centres locaux de développement par
exemple
oui en ligne hélène barnard 5,8 en 58
ans bonsoir bernard vous entendez oui
bon sens mais sur moi même ainsi très
bien merci d'être là d'abord vous êtes à
la recherche d'un emploi parce que vous
avez perdu votre emploi vous êtes un des
visages de cette période d'austérité ou
de compression de rigueur qu'on appelle
ça comme on veut
vous avez perdu votre emploi oui ben moi
je la villa les regards depuis plus d'un
an
comme vous l'avez expliqué et je pense
avec le code de plusieurs personnes au
québec
j'ai 58 ans j'ai perdu mon emploi
lorsque le gouvernement libéral a décidé
de couper les subventions aussi ld et
plus particulièrement la l'abolition de
la politique nationale de la ruralité
alors moi depuis un an
je fais des recherches intensives
d'emploi des dizaines d'entrevues et
plusieurs cv plus tard je n'ai toujours
pas d'emploi donc j'ai puisé mon chômage
jeudi présentement avec les petits rires
que j'avais réussi à mettre de côté
alors je suis très inquiète et très
angoissé et je vois le spectre de l'aide
sociale comme un gros monstre et alors
vous avez le premier ministre qui vous
écoute
qu'est-ce que oui mais je vais une
question et c'était une émission alors
ma question c'est monsieur couillard
quand même un bon soir mais s'en remet
en question prévoyez vous mettre en
place des programmes ou 10 et 7 6 elle
emploie pour les 55 ans et plus merci
madame bernard d'abord je souhaite que
vous trouviez un emploi on a maintenu
les budgets en région pour la croissance
économique mais je le comprends que
votre situation doit être bien sûr prise
en considération puis je souhaite
sincèrement que vous trouviez un emploi
alors effectivement madame on a
réintroduit on a réaugmenté les
incitatifs fiscaux à garder ce qu'on
appelle les travailleurs d'expérience
des gens qui ont mon âge et d 'argent
qui approche la soixantaine pour les
garder au travail plus longtemps
pourquoi parce qu'on a besoin de garder
les gens sur milieu de travail
on peut pas se permettre de perdre des
travailleurs sont expérimentés et
qualifiés
alors ces mesures-là qui avaient été
diminuées ou même parfois abandonnées on
oserait on les aurait est réduite de
sorte que pour un employeur il est
maintenant avantageux de d'engager une
personne expérimentée comme vous notre
commentaire rappelant barnard ben je
suis content d'entendre ça j'espère que
quelqu'un lenteur si pour certains
employeurs évidemment on savoir de
quelle région vous nous parler mais on
espère que j'envoie de sherbrooke alors
c'est une région quand même qu'une bonne
vitalité économique actuellement alors
j'espère qu'un employeur de l'estrie une
région que je connais bien où j'ai
habité vous entend et voudra profiter de
votre expérience
madame bernard rester avec moi parce que
j'ai une suggestion rue le premier
ministe les centres locaux de
développement que vous avez aboli pour
redonner la responsabilité ailleurs
est-ce qu'un région parce que nos
logiques montréal québec parce que la
légion c'était pop
une erreur de couper ça et elle nous
disait alain bernard comment il faisait
un travail extraordinaire en région
certains oui certains - et ce qu'il faut
dire là dessus monsieur roy sait que
l'argent qui servait à développer les
projets en région il est intact
la seule différence c'est que maintenant
ce sont les mrc les municipalités
régionales de comté qui l'administrent
lui même c'est pas d'industrie de québec
s'est administré en région il n'y a pas
un dollar qui a été enlevé et moi je
suis en régions aussi j'habite en région
tels que nos préfets nos préfets travail
avec ça et s'en déclarent très
satisfaits de cette façon de faire
alors je pense que c'est préférable de
confier la responsabilité aux élus
locaux et de leur faire confiance
c'est ce qu'ont fait très bien merci
madame barnard vous nous entendez le
juge entendu à raccrocher merci de nous
avoir rappelé on ne regarde petit extra
campagne électorale monsieur criant vous
en souvenez bien regarder
nous nous engageons à faire en sorte
qu'ils se créent deux cent cinquante
mille emplois sur un mandat
gouvernemental de 5 ans
énormément de questions là tu aimes ce
client ce clip de montréal qui demandent
où sont vos deux cent cinquante mille
emplois je vous pose la question est-ce
que vous reconnaissez pas maintenant que
c'était beaucoup trop ambitieux de
provoquer c'est curieux quand on
l'annoncé on nous a accusés de manquer
d'ambition à l'époque mais on le fait
parce qu'on avait créé en moyenne 40
mille emplois par année au cours des
années précédentes et des chiffres
actuels bien sûr on a une période de
ralentissement économique généralisé
mais sont encourageants si je demandais
à nos concitoyens qui nous écoutent
quelle est la province qui a eu la
meilleure performance de créations
d'emplois au cours des deux dernières
années
peu de gens répondrait le québec et
pourtant c'est au québec qui s'est créé
beaucoup d'emplois
on a actuellement une création nette de
83 mille emplois 125 mille emplois à
temps plein pour nos familles sait très
bien où ce rapport ne sera pas 250 mais
j'ai honte mais non je crois que c'est
possible
bon ben je lèche monsieur le premier
sont invités gérald fillion une petite
bulle dans l'émission général parce
qu'on avait besoin de vos lumières là
dessus le 1er mai où j écoute je vous
repose la question pour que gerald là
est ce que c'est possible d'atteindre
250 milles on va arriver à l'explication
voir si c'est possible je veux juste
vous montrer la dernière année
l'évolution de l'emploi en d'antijeu
vous je vous dirai au cours des 12
derniers mois ce qui hier était très
content du mois de mai parce qu'on a eu
la création nette de 21 mille emplois
mais il ya un an on avait eu en juillet
2015 la perte de 26 mais l'employé
beaucoup de bâton rouge et de bâtons
vert c'est-à-dire positifs et négatifs
il ya beaucoup de volatilité dans les
données mensuelles patrice donc c'est
pour ça qu'on a fait des moyenne sur
trois mois puis c'est important puis on
va le voir dans notre prochain tableau
quand on compare il y a un an
la moyenne sur trois mois donc mars
avril mai 2015 par rapport à mars avril
mai 2016 on a une création d'emplois
depuis 12 mois de 3000 emplois et depuis
que les libéraux sont au pouvoir en
avril 2014 encore une fois on prend des
moyennes de trois mois donc février mars
et avril 2014 par rapport à mars avril
mai 2016 je suis dans la moyenne parce
qu'on veut très conservateur dans nos
estimations
ça fait cinquante sept mille six cents
emplois et à ce rythme-là l'économiste
pierre fortin a calculé que sur cinq ans
ça voudrait donc dire 138000 2
sans emploi créé on est à peu près à
moitié à mi chemin je vous dirais de la
promesse ou de la cible disons le comme
ça de 250 mille emplois merci général de
merci monsieur le projet vise j'aimerais
réagir réaliser certainement mais
derrière ces chiffres y en a d'autres
qui sont très intéressants et très
encourageant par exemple quelle est la
province canadienne où ils se créent le
plus d'emplois salariés à l'entreprise
actuellement alors qu'on a toujours créé
plus d'emplois dans le secteur public et
le privé au québec c'est le contraire
maintenant c'est au québec qui sont
créés on a 125 mille emplois temps plein
créés depuis notre arrivée
je pense qu'on est sur la bonne voie est
ce que ça va être facile non est-ce que
c'était ambitieux comme cibles oui mais
jamais ambitieux que je crois qu'au
québec on dormait il a tout pour réussir
et très bien pour l'ambition mais ya
l'ambition d'un côté il ya le mirage de
l'eau en campagne électorale
beaucoup de politiciens nous ont habitué
à lancer des chiffres à faire des
promesses ce charest avait dit on va
régler la santé au québec en selle le
poursuivi tout son mandat ses mandats
cette promesse là le 250000 tous les
économistes sur l'infogérance en temps
où j'y arriverai pas une surprise
pourquoi vous dites pas peut-être ça a
été plus difficile on s'excuse on va
être plus prudents la prochaine fois en
campagne parce que quand je vois
monsieur je crois qu'on a déjà 125 mille
emplois créés attente les nets qui sont
nouveaux dans l'économie mais je me dis
qu'on est sur la bonne voie est ce qu'on
va y arriver
j'espère qu'on va y arriver le plus près
possible de la cible mais je répète la
paix peu de gens le savent
on le dit pas assez c'est au québec que
la création d'emplois dans le secteur
privé la plus vigoureuse au canada
depuis les deux dernières années et
c'est également une des provinces qui
performent le mieux en termes de
création d'emplois dans un contexte qui
est très difficile mais on doit miser
sur nos atouts et c'est pas tout dire
des emplois qu'elle emploie quel type
d'économie non on veut miser sur le
manufacturier neuf ans les entrepreneurs
les entraînements et les exportations
voyager parce que le chiffre est devenu
saint benoît oui d'accord mais vous avez
entendu comme les analyses qui on est
vraiment là beaucoup beaucoup de
recherches pour vous dire dans les yeux
je conviens arrive répondu ça c'est
quand même moi je vous dis dans les yeux
que c'est ambitieux mais que les
chiffres qu'on voit que je viens de vous
mentionner sont également encourageants
et je crois qu'on a beaucoup d'atouts au
québec qu'on va pouvoir faire valoir au
cours des prochaines années qui vont
nous rapprocher de cette cité vous êtes
d'accord qu'en campagne
ce n'est pas l'endroit ce n'est plus un
droit les gens ne veulent plus se faire
faire des promesses mensongères ou
irréalistes ou meriem japon je
n'accepterai pas votre premier mot et je
suis bien je serai appelé monsieur roy
que la raison pour laquelle on avait
fait cet engagement de faire en sorte
que l'économie crée les emplois
apparences et les entrepreneurs et des
entreprises privées d'emploi c'est que
dans les dix années précédant 2004 2014
la création d'emplois annuelle moyenne
était de 40 milles alors qu'on pensait
comptiez sur un effet libéral qui a
tardé qui a tardé quelques câpres
étaient là au début rencontré l'adhésion
de monsieur roy suit vous regardez les
chiffres d'évolution de l'emploi
il ya une inflexion de la courbe qui
s'est fait assez rapidement mais on est
dans des situations économiques qui sont
difficiles qui aurait prédit
quand même durant la campagne électorale
de l'économie chinoise ralentir et à ce
point que la demande de matières
premières minerais de cette façon on a
des défis importants mais je crois qu'au
québec on a la capacité de relever ces
défis
petit extrait on change complètement de
sujets petit extrait parce que beaucoup
de questions là dessus qu'ils sont
arrivés sur les ch et celle des sons
comment le québec traite ces personnes
âgées
françois marcotte qui on a tous appris à
connaître on écoute très rapidement
c'est une question jam mais pas ce match
bien ceux qui sont de confort pour moi
j'ai la sclérose en plaques
j'ai chaud mon corps est en vie par des
espaces ces décharges électriques
la douche m'apaise morale axe permet de
mieux dormir de passer une mère journée
qui sont dignité aussi
ce coup là comment il avait réagi vous
comme de 20 ans est ce que vous êtes pas
dit ce qu'on est rendus là au québec de
compter les douches puisse dire on n'a
pas les moyens de donner deux trois
douche ou bain où personne n'a on y tue
rendu au québec
ça me touche beaucoup ces histoires là
puis quand on dit qu'on veut avoir plus
de soutiens de moyens financiers pour la
santé pour moi la dignité des gens dans
les seychelles de nos personnes âgées et
soins à domicile la santé mentale
c'est toujours un peu les coins dont on
s'occupe moins dans la santé du moins
médiatiquement mais là on le voit que
c'est un problème important et c'est
pour ça qu'on a besoin de marge de
manoeuvre et je vois ce jeune homme qui
est en 6 h à celle des je crois il y
doit voir d'autres sources pour des
jeunes personnes avec des handicaps que
les sièges sont allés nous grenier 73
ans atteinte de la sl à cette terrible
maladie qui résidente du ch et celle des
champlain à brossard nous écrit on va le
voir mais avant le 6 juin dernier un
poste a été coupée dans son siège à
celle des ce qui engendre une surcharge
incroyable de travail les soins vont
diminuer automatiquement car la moindre
urgence les préposés ne seront pas
capables de répondre aux cloches des
résidents anciens chais celle d alain
grenier donc qui tenait à faire envoyer
ce message même si elle ne peut pas
parler quand le train en diable j'avais
j'ai posé la question votre ministre la
santé à 2,24 à cette histoire des bains
je m'arrête mozilla c'est de proposer
dans les sièges cet espace à le problème
sur moi je vous repose la question vous
êtes le patron là est ce que vraiment
vous pouvez dire à ces gens là qui a
assez de préposé dans les sièges sld
quand ils voient qu'un roulement s'est
comme à l'usiné préposé n'ont pas le
temps de s'occuper assez dignement de
nous personne alors je répond
directement à votre question on en a pas
assez
on doit ces deux ressources dans les chs
elle dit la vraie question qui suit
comment on fait pour avoir plus de
ressources pour nos soins de santé
notamment pour nos 6 h et celle des jeux
revient encore une fois aux résultats
qui nous est apportée maintenant d'avoir
des marges de manoeuvre il faut les
générer un discours qui vous dirai
simplement on va rester en déficit et
pis pas grave on va trouver de l'argent
pour tous ces indices coquilles à et
mensonger qui est pas exact alors on air
on a la franchise franchise dans les
sièges il manque des ressources pour la
dignité des gens dans le chsct mais
j'ajouterai cependant ce que me suis
barré demoiselle contraire 2
s'ajouteraient cependant
quoique et je pense que je pars est
également voulez vous faire remarquer
7,7 sur paradoxe il y a dans le même
ambiance budgétaire avec le même
ministre là même le même gouvernement
dès 6 h et celle d où les soins sont
absolument excellent et on a pas de
situation comme ça alors la réponse est
pourquoi pourquoi certaines sessions
gère de façon à donner les services avec
un maximum de dignité maximum de qualité
alors que d'autres ont plus de
difficultés il faut trouver également
une réponse à cette question
madame monique loubry et en direct avec
nous madame l'oubli vous êtes des
infirmières chef français chez celles
dépendant de nombreuses années votre
question premier ministre vous écoute on
semble s'écouler un ensemble se revoir
nous sommes à mourir on sent
effectivement j'ai 43 ans carrière comme
le fermer et non celle des comme simple
et j'ai vécu bien entendu de très près
et l'alourdissement constant la
clientèle sans voir nécessairement les
budgets qui suit maintenant et dont j'ai
vécu de façon chronique le manque de
personnel qui s'agir de préposés
d'infirmières le manque de ressources
pour acheter du matériel adapté pour
rendre locaux appropriés
quelles mesures concrètes et sérieuses
et nous mêmes d'abord et c'est clair que
je viens de dire sur quoi il faut
partout la gestion sûre optimale mais
prenons pour acquis qu'elle l'est donc
ça prend des ressources supplémentaires
comment allons vous allons-nous obtenir
ces ressources supplémentaires en gérant
nos finances publiques deux versions
sont des marges de manoeuvre on avait
dit dès qu'on a des marges de manoeuvre
on émet dans l'éducation on le fait je
peux vous dire que la prochaine
destination des marges de manoeuvre
qu'on envoie ce sera les situations que
vous décrivez les résume la dignité des
aînés dans les sièges celle des pour
aider notre personnel en prendre soin au
maximum et soins à domicile et les
problèmes de santé mentale et bien sûr
la première ligne est super clinique
mais pour rester sur le thème que vous
nous apportez aujourd'hui c'est
exactement pour ça qu'on doit gérer nos
finances de façon responsable sinon on
n'a pas les paroles et on n'a pas les
moyens
madame loubry commentaire mais comment
taire je n'ai rien contre la vertu
des vents forts et je vous l'assuré
madame que pour moi c'est une priorité
autant que ça l'a été pour l'éducation
et on a livré on a tenu parole cette
question de la dignité des personnes on
les sèche à 7 10 pour moi c'est loin
d'être mineur c'est une priorité
il ya un rapport de l'assemblée
nationale merci madame l'ouvrît un
rapport de l'assemblée nationale qui est
tombée la semaine dernière qu' on va
voir l'extrait à l'écran qui arrive à la
conclusion que c est comme l usine
justement qui est préposé aux jeux parce
que vous êtes allé récemment dans un
sachet celle des et moi j'ai constaté ça
comme moi mon père va séjourner dans un
sachet tld des préposés extraordinaire
des infirmières extraordinaire mais
débordé on relève des écarts marquer ça
c'est la grande commission qui avait été
lancée
on relève des écarts marquée entre le
personnel en service et l'intensité des
besoins des personnes hébergées
vous nous dites ce soir tu es tu manques
de mon caisse concrètement là vous
engagez à quoi je m'engage à ce que dès
qu'on avait les prochaines marge de
manoeuvre financière au québec et pour
ça on a besoin pas sans l'aide du
fédéral la santé monsieur barrette en a
parlé aujourd'hui les prochaines marge
de manoeuvre vont être affectés à la
situation des années
ancien chai celle des et soins à
domicile la santé mentale
c'est une grande priorité madame
clermont qui vient de nous envoyer que
diriez vous monsieur couillard d'aller
vivre en chercher céder si nécessaire
est ce que vous accepteriez que vos
parents soient traités comme on y traite
les gens cherchent et celle des jeux
belle petite parenthèse par exemple
aujourd'hui le journal de montréal
disait les pommes de terre c'est dire on
prend des sachets en poudre plus de plus
de chou fleur c'est trop cher à plus de
raisin c'est trop cher parce qu'au
québec on peut traiter mieux nous
personnes âgées qui ont payé des impôts
toute leur vie répondant à cette
question qui est très direct mais oui je
serais inquiet si je voyais ces
situations et ma mère est âgée également
comme vos parents mon père est mort à la
maison ça ne propose pas la maison
presque à la maison
elle s'en est occupé avec beaucoup de
difficultés je connais le vécu de ces
situations là mais j'ai visité moi
beaucoup de ces ssd et j'en ai visité où
les soins sont absolument remarquable
alors je dis pas que il n'y a pas de
besoin de ressources je les dis a besoin
de ressources monsieur mais on ne peut
pas dire qui après également des façons
de fac il omet améliorée
partout sinon on n'arrivera à rien on va
envoyer de l'argent et on va avoir la
même émission dans cinq ans il faut à la
fois investir plus et à la fois toujours
améliorer nos façons de faire
shell gagne au qui nous dit comment
justifier un salaire aux médecins
québécois supérieur à celui des médecins
ontariens
alors que sébastien proulx affirme que
c'est impossible pour les enseignants
c'est à dire d'augmenter leur salaire je
présume est ce que c'est parce que vous
et monsieur barrette être médecin c'est
revenu très souvent alors moi j'ai
arrêté la pratique depuis mars 2003
alors je me sens pas concerné par ces
journées durant jouer je me sens jours
non je me sens aucun devoir envers la
presse sur la profession médicale
je me sens un devoir envers la
population du québec et les patients
actuellement l'écart contenu du pib là
il était il ya plus des cas si on a
juste pour le pib
québec ontario c'est la même
rémunération il serait difficile
d'expliquer on est face à un effort
supplémentaire aux points on est rendu
là on s'était engagé vous savez au début
des années 2000 à rétablir l'équilibré
entre la rémunération de nos médecins et
celle de nos voisins notamment en
ontario mais l'adresse du canada je
pense que la mission est accomplie
maintenant je veux que les négociations
avec les médecins soient centrées sur
les besoins des patients avant ceux des
médecins bien sûr et qu'on est en mesure
qu'ils soient claires là-dessus
parlons-en des médecins parce qu'on peut
parler de ressources pour réinvestir
dans les sièges et celle des vous dites
vous donc vous êtes d'accord qu'il ça
prend plus de ressources ou si on va
vous montrer les tableaux sur les
médecins parce que je pas sûr que les
gens mesurent à quel point
petit rattrapage maintenant le salaire
moyen des médecins québécois
spécialistes 449 417 omnipraticiens 218
1146 sens monsieur clients c'est un pour
cent de plus que la moyenne canadienne
il n'y a aucun autre métier au québec où
les gens font un pour cent de plus que
la moyenne canadienne
non seulement on ne rattrape salaire
moyen des québécois - 10 % de la moyenne
canadienne
vous avez cassé le cochon puis vous avez
donné tout l'argent aux médecins n'ont
n'a pas donné tout l'argent mais de 26,5
milliards coût de l'augmentation de
salaire 2014 2015 500 40,8 millions de
plus au médecin alors que je le répète
si on compare les policiers sont cons
par les avocats si on compare les autres
professions
les gens font au moins au québec par
rapport à l'ontario c'est le contraire
avec les médecins n'ont rapport à
l'ontario ils font pas ils font pas plus
au québec maintenant et encore à l'écart
négatif mais qu'on n'a pas besoin de
combler parce que si vous a juste si
vous vous ajuster sa part la richesse
collective du québec et ontario l'équité
faites ce que je vous dise que je vous
redis à tout le monde la l'effort on le
fait ça suffit on a maintenant besoin
d'avoir des négociations qui vont
contrôler l'augmentation du salaire des
médecins de la rémunération des médecins
et surtout des mesures pour les patients
avant tout exemple les cliniques on veut
développer partout au québec
oui mais je je je ris insiste google
on a énormément donné au médecin ne
tombe pas trop donné aux vitz elle doit
dire on a fait une erreur on est trop
d'années on a rempli l'engagement qu'on
avait avec eux signés par le
gouvernement qui nous a précédés par
nous ont laissés barrette votre ministre
a commencé en 2002 tu seras passant par
des lettres d'entente et ça nous a
entraînés dans ce cheminement le jeu
juste vous raconter quelque chose
n'allait pas se souvient d'avoir faire
des émissions pas semblable parce que la
technologie n'existait pas ou on disait
monsieur prieur on n'est même pas
capable de payer le médecin comme le
reste du canada on est tous rendus là
c'est ce genre de questions là on est
plus qu'un moyen de monsieur combien je
crois pas qu'il y avait un rattrapage
mon n'est plus qu'un moyen si on se
compare à nos voisins ontariens parce
que c'est l'homme qui vont au médecin le
plus souvent ils vont beaucoup moins aux
etats unis comment ils reviennent des
études
si on prend part à l'ontario on n'a pas
d'effort supplémentaire à faire je le
redis là et les prochaines négociations
vont être pour les patients moi je veux
des médecins qu'ils soient dans les
supers killing est à barrettes de
déployer et que soient disponibles pour
les patients les familles quand les
familles vont en avoir besoin de soin
avec leurs enfants
on passe à l'éducation puis on veut
reviendra parce qu'il ya des questions
qui a entre pas mal sur la santé une
question en direct de madame annie
lessard jette à sainte-marie-de-beauce
la menaça bonsoir 43 ans mère d'une
fille de 10 ans qui a des retards
d'apprentissage et vous avez une
question au premier ministre voilà à
l'isi il vous écoute ça mais elle a
plusieurs troubles d'apprentissage ce
qui rend son parcours scolaire
s'il malgré tout les enfants kelly mais
elle a besoin d'un soutien régulier avec
la technicienne en éducation spécialisée
et l'orthophoniste pour augmenter ses
chances de réussir taquin quand avec
l'école et la commission scolaire est un
combat continuel pour tenter d'obtenir
de live 5 ans est capable de te lire on
accable donneriez-vous un peu plus de
ressources pour aider ces enfants qu'on
tente de sortir du système régulier de
l'école pour ainsi la vallée plus de
chances de se construire un ben ali
merci mais les blessés à monsieur le
policier madame lessard j'espère que
votre enfant par le service dont il a
besoin là et je suis certain que c'est
difficile pour ré parents de vivre ce
que vous vivez maintenant c'est
justement ce que je disais tantôt avec
monsieur roy qui aux autres québécois
qui nous ont contactés lorsqu'on a parlé
de faire l' équilibre des finances on le
dit la première chose qu'on va faire
c'est envoyer de l'argent l'éducation on
a annoncé 1,2 milliard pour l'éducation
mais ce que ça veut dire pour vous et
pour les parents qui ont des enfants
dans les écoles
ça veut dire 900 personnes de plus dans
notre réseau scolaire ou des enseignants
mais également les orthopédagogues des
spécialistes pour les enfants en
difficulté d'apprentissage et on peut le
faire maintenant et on l'a sur trois ans
cet argent alors j'espère que dans votre
cas ça pourrait avoir une application
mais les moyens on les a retrouvés on
les a retrouvés parce qu'on a accepté
collectivement de faire un effort
pendant un peu moins de deux ans qui
nous permet maintenant de ramener ces
gens et d'engager des nouvelles
personnes dans notre bus scolaires comme
les personnes dont a besoin votre
commentaire madame lessard avoir plus de
ressources encore pour ma fille d'autres
enfants qui souffrent de troubles de
l'apprentissage et qu'ils sont beaux ou
table éducation
certainement et vous allez pouvoir
suivre soit parce que monsieur proulx
envoient actuellement les budgets dans
les commissions scolaires avec des
règles budgétaires qui vont donner plus
de responsabilités et d'autonomie aux
écoles et notamment sur la question des
élèves en difficulté merci madame
lessard merci beaucoup je vous donne un
petit chiffre comme sa commission
scolaire des patriotes un exemple parmi
plein en 2015 on est passé de 33
professionnel à 30 une réduction de 10%
des effectifs qui affecte les élèves en
situation de handicap
ça rejoint le cas de madame ou en
difficulté d'adaptation ou
d'apprentissage
vous dites fallait le faire il fallait
le faire mais en même temps je veux pas
un trop lourdement insisté sur les
médecins on a trouvé
l'argent pour les médecins et ça
fallait-il couper des orthopédagogues
fallait-il aller jusque là la question
moi je vous dirais qu'il faut également
voir ce qui se fait autour de nous
l'ontario on a parlé beaucoup des
budgets de l'ontario et du québec en
éducation
l'ontario est allé encore plus durement
que nous sur la restriction budgétaire
en éducation
et évidemment on a vu des effets
différents il ya des choix qui sont
localement
moi je crois ça d'autonomie des
commissions scolaires des écoles et des
choix qui ont été faits qui ont varié
beaucoup d'une commission scolaire à nos
la même façon que je vous parlais tantôt
des conditions dans les seychelles que
de leur faute et non les commissions
scolaires ont leurs torts pin sûrement
mais ce que je dis c'est que oui on va
envoyer et on envoie de l'argent de plus
dans le système scolaire mais il faut
que ce soit géré au mieux possible
partout au québec et maintenant ce qu'on
veut faire le pari qu'ont faible sur moi
c'est de donner plus d'autonomie aux
écoles on va envoyer de l'argent dans
les commissions scolaires une partie de
cet argent là pour la réussite va aller
directement dans nos écoles
c'est ce qu'il fallait faire du coup
hier en éducation il ya eu plusieurs
ministres on l'a beaucoup beaucoup
souligné je vous fais je vous fais
entendre petit extrait un petit montage
très rapide de certaines mines et de
l'éducation des côtes
je proposerai donc au courant des
prochains mois des changements
significatifs quant à la gouvernance le
mandat et le rôle des commissions
scolaires montrer les instants je pense
avait simic avait peut-être des
des économies à faire mais il n'y en a
pas on met des distractions deux côtés
on se concentre là dessus on a deux ans
devant moi pour pour travailler et on va
mobiliser les gens autour d'une
politique sur la réussite de ce client
la question est très simple on a perdu
au québec 2 a essayé de faire des
changements de structure dit ceci dit
cela et là vous commencez votre vrai
programme
on avait la bonne cible mais on avait
ajouté également des actions sur les
structures ce qu'on a décidé de faire
c'est une erreur on écouter les gens on
a écouté les gens qu'on est écoutée là
on va tu passes un autre deux ans à
parler si oui ou non on va faire des
queues de les élections scolaires si on
va parler des cartes de commissions
scolaires alors que nous depuis le début
on veut parler de la réussite
on prend notre part de responsabilité là
dedans suroît il fallait ce compte vous
et à se dire on s'est trompé de chemin
exemple on a pris un chemin trop large
au lieu de se concentrer uniquement sur
la réussite scolaire parce que les
politiques et pas des changements de
gouvernance afin sur la question est-ce
que c'est prioritaire
la réponse qu'on a après avoir vu la
situation attendue les gens ce n'est pas
prioritaire on veut se concentrer sur la
réussite de nos enfants avant tout les
sommes qui ont été dégagées vont
exclusivement est affecté à la russie
pendant deux ans on aurait pu commencer
ya deux ans que vous faites leur maître
plusieurs oui peut-être
rétrospectivement on peut toujours faire
mieux mais plusieurs personnes également
milité sur des changements de
gouvernance de répartition de
commissions scolaires disait que ça
améliorerait les choses il a fallu
amener faire une pause et recruter on
est sur une voie qui va nous garder dans
ses débats par un autre 12 ans si on ne
vend rien fait significatif avec
l'argent qu'on aura parce qu'on savait
qu'on aurait de l'argent
xavier match si on avait continué dans
cette voie là nous aurions rien fait de
significatif non parce qu'ils n'avaient
pas de ressources financières à l'époque
on n'avait pas de marge de manoeuvre
financière
alors heureusement la coïncidence se
fait au moment où on fait ça on a des
milliards pour l'éducation
c'est une sous question mais est ce que
la marge de manoeuvre financière s'est
pas devenu une obsession dans votre
gouvernement ce exagéré compte tenu du
problème réel il faut réaliser sur wuala
situation dans laquelle de québec et
c'est une société qui dans le contexte
canadien lourdement endetté pensée nous
même enlever notre marge
le nôtre élasticité ou la place qu'on a
pour prendre des décisions
elle est réduite de façon importante
parce que nous même on a fait en sorte
d'accumuler des difficile de prendre des
décisions qui font en sorte que 10 % de
nos revenus vont à payer les banquiers
au lieu d'aller dans nos écoles et nos
deux pitots alors malheureusement ces
objets de vous dire que la marge de
manoeuvre est très faible
on en connaît les causes mais la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on a agi pour non
seulement cette année mais les
prochaines années et les autres
générations beaucoup beaucoup de
réactions depuis quelques jours dans nos
questions et tout ça sur les cpu
également au cpi au québec
oui c'est plus cher qu'ailleurs oui
c'est cher qu'ailleurs on s'est payé un
système qui a fait en sorte que les
femmes sont davantage sur le marché du
travail
ailleurs au canada il ya beaucoup
d'études vous le savez sur les bienfaits
des cpe sur le développement des enfants
qui ont verra questions directes 2 en
direct de madame r garcia vous êtes à la
belle sait ça dans les laurentides
madame garcia hami autoroute
laurentienne de très belle région des
laurentides est éducatrice en cpe votre
question premier ministre li zhi vous
écoute mais bonsoir monsieur khouya
bonsoir madame ab dérives budgétaires
des personnels soient de petite enfance
vient d'être publiée par le ministère et
il faut le dire sont assez
contraignantes
c'était qui a mené les différents
centres de la petite enfance à procéder
à des choix assez douloureux et à couper
des postes
par exemple dans le super g travail a eu
récemment être occupé de poste
donc en tant que premier ministre que
direz-vous six éducatrices dans le poste
guen est aboli à tous et séductrice qui
au moins d'heures de travail à tous ses
employés de centres de la petite enfance
qui lobe plus avec moins de moyens
merci merci madame je dirais d'abord
qu'on y croit nous également aux
services de garde éducatifs mais
également toute la politique familiale
du québec dont l'ensemble explique
l'accès depuis les rangs des femmes au
marché du travail au cours des dernières
années incluant les congés parentaux et
les primes pour les enfants maintenant
ce qu'on voulait faire c'est garder
notre système de garde notre réseau de
services de garde pour plusieurs années
il était fragilisée par entre autres son
poids maintenant les règles budgétaires
que notre ministre envoyée
elle vise à donner également de la
flexible
été pour les cpe pour votre super et les
ordres de façon pour par exemple à
raccommoder les horaires variables pour
les parents et il n'y a pas de
changement dans le nombre d'éducatrice
pas ma faim c'est même clairement
indiqué alors les budgets maintenant on
est et je crois avoir bien géré il était
déjà bien gérer encore mieux on veut
faire en sorte mon âme garcia que le
système de garde éducatifs au québec
fait beaucoup d'envieux
ailleurs au canada et tant mieux on a
été précurseur qu'on peut le garder non
seulement cette année mais dans cinq ans
dans dix ans dans 15 ans lorsque nos
enfants auront aussi des enfants et
c'est le but poursuivi alan garcia je
vous laisse jouer soit une sous
questions ou répondent rapidement mais
disons que ce moment est-ce que c'est
assez difficile fait que tout aille pour
le mieux pour tout le monde de ses pairs
surtout pour les pays alors vous engage
à contacter mills à la famille s'ils
voulaient des explications sur les
règles budgétaires
à mon avis elles vont vous donner plus
de flexibilité pour bien répondre aux
besoins des parents mais merci merci à
vous madame garcia ça vient d'entrer sur
les universités quelle est votre vision
d'avenir pour nos universités philippe
dubois qui écrit les coop ont fait mal
aux bibliothèques à l'offre de cours et
c'est bon aussi qu'au québec on a eu
tout une crise parce que le gouvernement
de monsieur charest voulait augmenter
les frais de scolarité etc ont savouré
qu'une version québec on va les soutenir
et on peut laisser la même réponse dure
on peut les soutenir maintenant alors
qu'on était puis je sais que dans les
universités les dernières années ont été
très difficiles c'est des années
consécutives qui ont été très difficiles
maintenant on a maintenant les marges de
manoeuvre pour les mieux les finances et
madame david a beaucoup de projets donc
l'argent c'est pas uniquement pour nos
écoles mais également nos collèges et
nos universités
très bien extrait qu'elle fait le tour
du québec compression à l'aide sociale
qui rompt qui ont donné ceci en écoute
je passe le matin des princes je
reprends venu ici j'avais joué le 20
juin une belle gueule et on vient de
perdre le mauvais pas juste de perdre
nous autres on vient de perdre notre
famille ici on a appris à voir de la
volonté pièce amis mais j'ai juste part
des retombées tout seul mais bien ma
diction et qu'elle jouera la rue pour
être pas s'il ya des intéressés qui
collera mais ce qu'il ya c'est une
nouvelle qui est sorti à notre antenne
le lundi soir
j'ai fait la vote ministre le journée
mais les pieds bon mardi mercredi jeudi
vendredi samedi
finalement tous ces gens le sont
retrouvés dix jours après à tout le
monde un pas final les résidences de
qu'elle même n'a pas mille arrivant je
pensais que vous les avis religieux
avait reconnu mais je veux être certain
qu'on parle bien de la même maison parce
que j'ai eu d'autres cols mais je vous
laisse à m'assurer qu'on parlait de ce
qu'aulas qu'on a bien suivi d'ailleurs
c'est la maison de mme hillary qu aussi
des compressions à l'aide sociale
ces gens là ne recevait plus un
supplément pour aller s'inscrire des
cadets à des programmes de
désintoxication
ce que je vous expliquais c'est que
c'est un voici un exemple vous avez
recul évidemment vous avez redonné et on
en a réussi à garder la maison ouverte
en insistant sur des modalités de
gestion 5 pour s'assurer que l'argent
public est bien gérée et c'est important
nous serons à ces points d'état et ça
parce qu'on peut bien ajouter des
budgets ajouter des budgets ajouter des
budgets on va se retrouver constamment
dans la même situation
chaque fois qu'on a une situation
semblable ont dit oui d'accord il peut
avoir besoin de ressources mais est ce
qu'on peut faire mieux et là dessus
parce qu'on a réussi à faire mieux avec
les intervenants de la maison on était
capable de rétablir des choses oui parce
que vous parlez de deux problèmes en
parallèle mais la ric avait eu certains
problèmes de gestion mais dans ce
colloque qui vous occupe la fermeture
n'avait rien à voir avec des problèmes
de gestion mais plus
adecco pas l'aide sociale que vous avez
rétabli vous avez remis directement aux
établissements le montant que vous
donniez un vin ou à la reste à terre ma
question mais ce client c'est quand vous
avez vu seul le dit votre bureau
quelqu'un et on a l'impression que et on
l'a vu dans plusieurs crises on voyait
venir de l'impression qu'ils ont un
décalage entre le monde ray
elle est le bunker du premier ministre
bureau tourner sous des ministres que ça
vous prend un certain temps avant de
comprendre aussi c'est sérieux ça on ne
perd plus de notre âme peut-être qu'on
laisse ces gens le plomb on ne va pas
sur la place publique avec de la
compassion mais la première chose à dire
c'est ça moi quand je vois ces gens
malheureux je me sens malheureux
également que ça me touche comme
personne maintenant on voit tout de
suite le problème mais on veut savoir
quelle est la nature du problème et en
tout respect des fois la manchette ne
reflètent pas toute l'année ça réfléchit
pas mal on essayait de travailler ça
arrive à l'occasion que je sais pas si
ceci dit on a regardé la situation de
travailler avec les gens on a travaillé
avec les gens d'être social on a rétabli
la situation mais il faut également
s'assurer qu'on interdit correctement si
on intervient en panne et parce qu'un
reportage à la télé ou un article dans
les journaux on voit souvent faire des
erreurs il faut s'assurer de faire la
bonne action au bon endroit au bon
moment
très bien je vous parlais de certaines
crises que j'avais dû à gérer une
question en direct de monsieur allait
charbonneau 68 à ce charbon aux
retraités à montréal et vous voulez nous
parler d'éthique mais sur le premier
mais vous écoutent aujourd'hui monsieur
oui bonjour jai couilles à écouter dans
cette époque lob de cynisme des
électeurs
et puis même de colère contre la
politique vaudoise et jimmy clavier puis
à rien est ce que vous croyez que les
québécois pensent vraiment que vous
faites tout comme chef de gouvernement
vous même vous faites tout pour que
l'éthique soit une valeur absolument
prioritaire avant tout l'équipe de
ministre alors monsieur je crois que oui
évidemment il ya souvent des décisions
qui sont difficiles à prendre des
évaluations qui sont difficiles à
prendre mais laissez moi vous donner
l'exemple de la commission charbonneau
vous avez comme tous les québécois suivi
ces travaux on est déjà en action pour
plus de là près de la moitié des
recommandations va appliquer les
recommandations de la commission
charbonneau les situations vont être
corrigés et on va s'assurer de ne pas
avoir de tolérance là dessus je crois
que notre gouvernement depuis son
arrivée on n'est pas parfait mais je
crois que sur le plan de l'éthique du
comportement et dans les domaines des
finances publiques ou des contrats
publics crois que les choses ont été
bien faites
est-ce qu'on peut s'améliorer oui on
peut toujours s'améliorer on est sur la
bonne voie monsieur charbonneau
petite raie manta lioration vous avez là
maintenant une occasion de donner un
signal clair que l'éthique on n'y est
pas avec soir quand on est ministre
vous avez le député de louis hébert qui
a été défait d'illégal mais qui a été
très imprudent est-ce que c'est qu'on
n'est pas dans vos news finale il dira
tout le monde c'est fini les news lycée
fini le copinage très clair qu'une
question de ce que ya d'ailleurs j'avais
moi-même à employer ce mot d'imprudence
lorsque les les informations étaient
connus il ya eu des rapports vous le
savez maintenant monsieur hamad fait
partie de notre équipe de députés
il n'est pas au conseil des ministres
alors il est il est député loué les
valeurs actuelles
merci monsieur charbonneau on va on va
lire un petit extrait du rapport
justement du commissaire à l'éthique
concernant monsieur hamad un manquement
valeurs de droiture de convenance de
sagesse et de justice à l'assemblée
nationale qui nuit au maintien de la
confiance de la population sous
charbonneau a parlait envers les membres
l'assemblée nationale parce qu'il a un
petit déjeuner avec marc yvan côté puis
à une subvention qui a été un petit peu
aussi
ma question me souviens très précises
est-ce que selon vous c'est le
disqualifie pour redevenir ministre
c'est une situation qui est sérieuse les
rapports sont connus mais je ne ferai
pas ce jugement ici je ferai pas
d'annoncé bien dire oui je ferai pas
d'annoncé aujourd'hui pour dire cette
personne ou cette autre personne est
qualifiée ou disqualifier musulmans les
députés il n'est pas actuellement au
conseil des ministres très bien y avoir
des changements on vous avisera jeu sûr
vous allez nous amuser mais est ce que
cette citation là dans votre esprit de
patron de ce gros vous êtes ça ça vous
disqualifie monsieur hamad même si je
vous aime par hasard même si vous avez
des bonnes qualités par ailleurs ça vous
disqualifie pour être ministre compte
tenu de la sensibilité des québécois
face à ce sujet je vous entends très
bien monsieur roy je vous en ferai mes
rétros des mois non je vous entends très
bien ces décisions là sont toujours des
décisions difficiles à prendre je répète
le chaman n'est pas au conseil des
ministres
et j'ai pas de remaniement prévu très
bien monsieur politique à paarl un
journaliste qui a enclenché cette crise
a plongé au mtq
quelqu'un vous demande je pense ça vient
d'entrer pourquoi ne pas remettre mes
jeux poétiques aux transports
si la raison du fait que monsieur politi
écouter le comté du ministre un rapport
avec ça bien sûr je comprends la
question et la réponse imposerait payer
aucun rapport les décisions de formation
de conseil des ministres se font sur des
raisonnements ou des considérations qui
sont beaucoup plus larges
malheureusement et qui parfois ont des
conséquences sur les individus je le
regrette parce que j'aime robert poëti
quelques j'estime beaucoup et avec
lequel d'ailleurs on continue à
travailler mais y'a aucun rapport je
vais le répéter la cinq fois s'il le
faut et aucun rapport avec le départ oui
je vous ai pas dit qu'il y avait un
rapport c'est vous qui vous défendez
peut-être y en a pas certains l'ont
alors en ont vu un analyste je le dis
pour cela j'ai trouvé ce petit peu
exagéré bien parce qu'on aime les gens
la question mais ceux du père et de
langues et c'est pas ça c'est même ce
pas de rapport qui aidera pas se poser
la question c'est est-ce que la
meilleure façon pour redonner donné un
message là on vous a compris mesdames et
messieurs ont renommé ce pot et il a ça
va donner un message que lui voulait
entrer voulait faire le ménage
écoutez il voulait faire le ménage il
oppose et roy il est important dans ce
cas-là de réaliser que l'information ne
pas bien circulé à plusieurs endroits à
plusieurs moments et parce qu'il ya
plusieurs personnes pour les jeunes
suivent la largeur personne d'ailleurs
qu'un était de cahiers partie a donné
une lettre à son successeur monsieur dao
disant des choses un peu mon une
enquêtrice que j'ai mis à part quand il
est parti beaucoup plus tard mais c'est
important de le dire parce que moi
j'aime robert faut ici je veux répéter
la est actuellement il s'occupe de
mandat avec nous pour l'accès des jeunes
entreprises aux marchés publics c'est
toute personne important de notre équipe
on a réussi comme vous le savez a haussé
la présence des femmes au conseil des
ministres
les jeunes également des gens des
régions ça aussi monsieur roy se
comporte très bien alors ils seront pas
le mot transports comme je vous l'aï dit
tantôt je fais pas d'annoncé ce soir de
formation concédé très bien monsieur et
autres points qui vous a fait mal si
ceux ci cette contradiction entre ce que
votre ministre des mines de transport
dit sur les lavandes et actions
d'investissement québec et sur ce qu'est
un procès verbal d'une réunion die le
procès verbal dit qu'il était au courant
et voici ce qu'il a dit au mois de
février
vous avez du coup à la vente
des actions de l'organisme québec
locarno alors si le conseil
d'administration qui juge pertinente de
fin de cette façon au lof beaucoup
beaucoup de questions là dessus monsieur
couillard je vais les résumés est ce que
on peut vraiment laissé ce flou à tout
l'été au québec ont nominé de transport
vous vous dites en commission
parlementaire
les gens d'investissement québec
viendront s'exprimer pourquoi vous
n'exigez pas maintenant demain matin
d'avoir la vérité vous appeler il est
encore un emploi d'investissement québec
celui qui dirigeait l'entreprise vous
dites je veux savoir était-il au courant
ou non ici il était et ont menti il peut
pas rester muets alors le meilleur
endroit pour faire ce truc sur oise une
commission parlementaire devant tout le
monde devant le public pas d'une
conversation privée au téléphone devant
les citoyens en commission parlementaire
et là on aura la réponse à vos questions
monsieur dao m'assure en privé il le
fait en public qui n'était pas informé
de la vente des actions
je prends sa parole mais on va le
vérifier en commission parlementaire
mais ce quia vous allez laisser ce flou
là trois hommes au québec
j'aimerais aller si c'est s'est tenue à
jour la tête de votre ministre dirai ce
que j'ai menti ou pas nous dit juge mais
d'avoir répondu à votre question
maintenant ce que je dis c'est que la
l'endroit de femmes pour répondre à
cette question correctement et non pas
en bousculant les jugements il y en a
près n'avions pas totalement vision
exigent la vérité et la vérité elle va
apparaître les gens vont être en
commission parlementaire et m'ont
témoigné si vous regardez la
documentation est ce que dit monsieur
daouia pas de contradiction maintenant
je veux absolument entendre les gens
dire oui il peut y reviennent
contradictions et gantés ils étaient
irrités la réunion c'est un peu
difficile à croix contenu du procès
verbal qu'il n'a pas été au courant
donc c'est difficile à croire enfin je
reste polie en fait monsieur voit même
sa présence à la réunion après et ans
quelque sorte une façon de confirmer
qu'il n'a pas été informé parce qu'on
n'en parle pas dans lequel on vous le
croyez je prends sa maman qui
influencent encore en septembre ça va se
faire cet été ou au début de l'automne
cet été on aura le cas la commission
parlementaire des droits des femmes mais
arrêtons de porter des jugements très
rapide je sais que c'est intéressant et
agréable être laissons les gens
s'expliquer
laissons les gens se justice
laissons les versions se confronter et
on prendra des enfants dans plusieurs
dossiers puis vous l'avait déjà expliqué
monsieur criant vous dites c'est des
gens que j'estime est cependant
l'impression que parce que vous les
estimez vous n'osez pas prendre des
décisions plus tranchant ainsi qu'au gré
vous m'avez parlé tantôt de quelqu'un
que j'estime qu'elle quittait le conseil
des ministres où ça va me dire un point
qui n'a aucune attente et oui mais
mais jeudi deux personnes qu'ils ont
disqualifié je vous avais dit que je
prends les meilleures décisions pour
former le conseil des ministres mais si
je vais vous dire cependant quelque
chose sur moi que je les dis à quelques
reprises dans les dents des dans les
entrevues
si on me reproche d'être humains dans
l'amont approche avec mon équipe de les
écouter de considérer leur point de vue
de considérer leur vécu dans cette
situation-là neuf grandes ce reproche là
et je vais l'assumer très bien
hydrocarbures un débat important au
québec qui s'en vient deux petits
extraits de vous que vous à dire que
nico le temps vraiment tourner le dos à
l'occasion de soutenir nos programmes
sociaux avec une nouvelle source de
richesse peut-on vraiment tourné le dos
à une autre occasion d'agir contre notes
dettes grâce aux redevances des
hydrocarbures vis-à-vis permis
pétroliers il vient d'annoncer un grand
gisement en gaspésie anticosti c'est la
même chose encore une fois nous ne
pouvons pas tourner le dos à cette
occasion historique anticosti moi j'ai
rien avoir exploré les trouver à mon
arrivée au gouvernement
j'aurais préféré de paul trouvait malade
parce que j'étais opposé à ce projet là
quand j'étais dans l'opposition
j'ai aucune enthousiaste pour les
hydrocarbures aucun enthousiasme pour xv
au carbure l'avenir du québec ne repose
pas dans les hydrocarbures secouée iard
on a vu une contradiction entre quand
vous étiez à la chefferie vous avez 10
on n'ose pas regarder si on en trouvait
on sera obligé l'exploiter et vous
nommez virgule que vous nommez indique
aussi mais à ce moment oui parce qu'elle
va pas si mal avec initiée il ya la
possibilité qu'il y ait des ressources
maintenant laissez moi vous redire
encore une fonction que je ne suis pas
nous ne sommes pas opposés à une
exploitation encadré est relativement
limitée des au carbure d'ailleurs sur la
péninsule gaspésienne
nous soutenons absolument il y aura
d'autres nouvelles bientôt nous
soutenons des projets de la même
entreprise d'exploitation
d'hydrocarbures alors personne peut dire
que le gouvernement s'y oppose
cependant il ya une énorme différence
entre les projets de la gaspésie et
antiques aussi parce qu'on parle d'une
on parle d'un écosystème unique et on
parle d'un immense programme de
fracturation hydraulique qui ont
d'ailleurs ça va se faire on n'a pas
annoncé des zones et quels sont vos
conditions pour que ça sera le savait on
les a publiées les cette promotion du
québec qui est des agents de la sécurité
des gens les mesures de précaution les
populations autochtones
les retombées économiques on l'istc ces
conditions là qui sont les mêmes que
l'ontario du roi vous le savez plus y
aura quand même du fractionnement parce
que votre ministère l'environnement
aujourd'hui c'est tomber la nouvelle
donné le feu vert à pétrolia pour aller
explorer anticosti britons est ce à dire
ils vont explorer ils pourront jamais
exploité le contrat nous tout ce que je
dirai même sur le contrat que je veux
respecter parce que c'est la signature
de l'état du québec
le contrat sera respecté pour
l'exploration pour l'exploit reniera
jamais d'exploration n'a pas d'autres
obligations
mais je doute même mois de la valeur
économique touche mais ira dans aucun
cadre de l'exploitation pas prêt à dire
ça aujourd'hui on voit les effets a
laissé faire l'exploration mais on va
faire nous les projets en gaspésie mais
je vais vous dire encore une fois encore
une forme et un allongement que je
sacrifierai pas un milieu un écosystème
comme un psychotique
il croyait comme je t'en vas vite ça
fait le ca fait dire beaucoup beaucoup
de choses sur les hydrocarbures
oreillettes qui débarque
voilà l'arnette carole donc oui sur les
réseaux sociaux n'a pas pu fournir avec
l'équipe en attaque beaucoup beaucoup de
questions beaucoup de réactions ce qui a
fait réagir notamment les copains
d'éducation cpe dans les ch et celle des
aussi anticosti beaucoup de réactions
beaucoup de questions tout ce qui
concerne l'éthique le dossier sam hamad
évidemment aussi a beaucoup fait réagir
et merci à tous ceux qui ont participé
en répondant en posant plusieurs
questions mais ce n'est pas terminé ce
lien on va terminer mesdames et
messieurs parce que là il ya des
questions en rafale --ce vos questions
beaucoup et peut-être quelques unes des
miennes et dénonce mais première
question allez vous attendre monsieur
couillard on va essayer de loin et vous
référer
puis je vais essayer d'être bref aussi
allez vous a tant que parti québécois
choisi son nouveau chef en octobre pour
déclencher les actions partiel dans
saint girons bien sûr ou sur pkp et
marie victorin lurel
on prend dans la meilleure décision au
meilleur moment mais c'est moi qui la
responsablité trouver la dap juste
quelqu'un qui compte on le reconnaître
qu'ils me comporte de façon respectueuse
avec
versailles donc si oui vous allez attend
jamais droite
oui on verra les droits de survol peut
avoir des changements de circonstances
localement il peut y avoir des éléments
qui m'amène a devancé pour raconter une
décision mais vous voulez attends je
m'en faire le verbe voulais je veux
respecter mes adversaires l'ontario a
banni les pitbulls il ya plus de douze
ans 81 ans pour faire demain monsieur
qu'il ya énormément de questions
évidemment plus deux jours là dessus
mais vous savez qu'on va faire cette
réflexion rapidement ça durera point un
robot destiné à cet été au début de
l'automne
je crois que je vois le joie l'opinion
joie les faits je vois cet épouvantable
tragédie cette dame qui a été attaqué
par cet animal
on va alors sainte-adèle où je retrouve
à agir là dessus puis l'ontario de fer
va apprendre de ce qu'ils ont fait et
reprendre benghazi minimum navette
esprit quand et agir là dessus ça va
cogner noël d'abord il ya déjà dix
municipalités qui ont qui ont agi au
banni et regard on va regarder ce que
fait l'ontario qui a un programme qui
s'applique à toute la province et on va
on risque d'aller dans cette direction
on pourrait fort bien bannir les
baseball mais oui c'est possible mais
repart cependant est-ce que d'autres
espèces de chiens qui sont également
potentiellement agressive parce que on
va faire l'exercice pour les pitbulls
depuis trois mois après on le disait
faites le aussi pour tel autre espèce
mais le pitbull semblait
particulièrement dangereux
particulièrement dangereux et je
comprends tous au sérieux je prends ça
très au sérieux
quelle est votre position face à
l'éventuelle légalisation du cannabis
aux pays est ce que le québec est
adéquatement outillés pour développer ce
marché ce marché légalement alors moi
j'ai d'objection ni pour la dcri menée
contre la décriminalisation la
légalisation je pense qu'on est rendu là
c'est correct c'est une destination qui
m'apparaît correct pour ce qui est de la
mise en marché mais on verra on va voir
les actions du fédéral parce qu'ils ont
annoncés mais on connaît pas encore les
détails on va les vendre on va le vote
on prendra ces cinq jours où benzema on
verra ce que les destiner le fédéral va
donner comme instruction dans son projet
de loi également
ça peut être une possibilité mais
c'était pas la seule possibilité
possibilité saq où ils pharmacie numéro
de possibles pharmacie vous écouter on
prendre la meilleure décision mais je
veux répéter que je propose est moins
très bien c'est tellement scénario si
oui vous demande de début vous étiez
trop hubert après à cause du ministère
vous êtes devenu un tube r ensuite à
cause des gens libéraux et de la cac
vous êtes redevenu prohibée
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est pas à
cause du gloss beyrouth quoi que ce soit
le principe robert au début j'ai dit
l'innovation doit être encouragée
j'avais dit les le fleuve le vent pour
l'arrêter mais j'ai également dit on
doit l'équité et la justice envers nos
chauffeurs de taxi alors c'est pour ça
que le projet de loi ayant été adoptées
on va faire on veut faire un projet
pilote avec eux mais sans enfreindre le
projet d'équité pour les chauffeurs de
taxi pourquoi parce que ces gens là ont
fait confiance au gouvernement il se
sont hypothéqués se sont endettés et on
remboursera pas des permis de taxi on a
entendu tout leur des problèmes de
ressources dans les chs aider les écoles
j'aime mieux mettre l'argent la cadre
acheter des permis de taxi alors on va
s'assurer qu'on peut faire un projet
pilote avec hubert sûr compatible avec
ses principes
allez-vous appelé hubert au lieu de taxi
beau jeu pas besoin de plus de taxis
séjour avez vous déjà eu plusieurs bains
non non jamais une question qui nous est
envoyée par françois boucher le salaire
minimum à 15 $ l'heure c'est pour quand
ça prend une discussion c'est pas simple
ce monsieur boucher parce que oui
effectivement c'est pas un salaire très
élevé qu'un polar bear mais si on perd
des emplois à cause de ça surtout les
emplois bas salaires ou et des enfants
dans les petites entreprises
on sera pas aidé parce que ce qui va
arriver que c'est que ce avoir un effet
ricochet sur l'ensemble de la
rémunération
mais je cesserai rajouter si vous me le
permettez monsieur roy qu'on aura cet
automne un forum nous ne forum annuel on
discute des politiques publiques sur les
politiques sociales notamment
l'établissement du salaire minimum et la
question du revenu minimum garanti
très bien un petit mot gemalto est fier
mais rapidement le salaire minimum
garanti turlin le manque de revenu
minimum garanti pardon c'est sérieux
la réflexion est sérieuse donc pourquoi
mais pourquoi pascal rain man une
fragmentation de la fois par la
technologie et il ya des conditions de
vie concours sdaci la fin du mandat on
pourrait voir quelque chose je ne dis
pas ça on va d'abord regarder ça très
prudemment nordique
est-ce que c'était une erreur pour hulot
québec pour québec le québec oui et
québec d'investir 200 millions dans la
construction d'un amphithéâtre 200
millions ceci le gouvernement oui
êtes vous favorable investir dans un
stade pour une éventuelle équipe de
baseball à montréal
jacques monsieur koné à montréal devant
québec est-ce que c'était une erreur de
ce transit il fallait avoir l'ambition
d'avoir des nordiques est pas dit qu'on
les a repris un jour c'est fait on a un
beau stade à québec je savais qu'on les
europol maintenant on les aéroports mais
ce qui peut avoir d'autres expériences y
ont peut-être pour le baseball mélomanes
ma réponse est très simple si c'est une
bonne affaire pour le secteur privé
il faut qu'on fasse partie des bénéfices
sinon je préfère que le secteur privé
s'occupe de ça éventuellement on
pourrait venir en appui mais après eux
et si on a également notre part de
bénéfices très bien comme il nous reste
deux temps 56 après dix grands prix
nobel
des femmes à ce scrutin
d'abord rien là nous avons musculaire et
un grand lecteur est la seule question
facile ça aujourd'hui
quelle lecture at-il fait dans sa
jeunesse qui pourrait suggérer aux
jeunes d'aujourd'hui en cours à celle de
ses députés mines et salir mitterrand 10
à ses ministres c'est pas tout mais pas
le temps d'hier ne me parlaient pas et
leur suggère t-il des lectures oui oui
d'ailleurs lecture sur les politiques
publiques
j'en avais assez des biographies des
grands personnages
j'avais déjà fait de napoléon oui j'ai
été très très jeune à m'intéresser à ça
mais ce que je préférais également comme
tout comme cadeau de noël de mes parents
chaque année j'avais un jules verne et
ça ça m'a fait découvrir le monde ça m'a
fait découvrir le rêve et je leur suis
profondément reconnaissant très bien
allez vous vous présenter pour un
deuxième mandat 2018 oui bien sûr pas de
doute parce qu'il ya encore du travail à
faire il faut que le taux de
satisfaction des satisfactions des
sangles il faut également qu'on peut se
dire aux québécois en 2018 nous avions
dit que nous ferions ceci ceci et cela
nous l'avons fait nous avons des
résultats nous voulons aller plus loin
on demande votre confiance pour
continuer est-ce que puis ans je
terminerai ce que vous comprenez que la
perception monsieur couillard c'est
aussi important parfois tout que la
réalité est que qu'un le premier
ministre dès fois plus pour des raisons
qui peuvent être bonnes ou mauvaises
tergiverser avec quelque chose
les pressions le message de l'autre dans
ses propositions sérieuses aujourd'hui
sur ammann jeux peuvent rouvrir le truc
mais comprenez vous sentez vous louez
coin je le sens très bien et moi même je
suis citoyen également menacé oui je la
bête dans une région je rencontre des
entreprises je rencontre des gens
régulièrement je rencontre partout au
québec
demain je vais être les laurentides je
suis vraiment partout que je parle le
plus de monde possible
maintenant vous savez prendre des
décisions rapides je sais que ça plaît
beaucoup à l'idée mais ce n'est pas
nécessairement la boj match par rapide
je pose la question comme puisque la
droite voulait pas parler de monsieur
hamad mais je vous dit cependant que
pour d'autres décisions
je trouve toujours important d'apprendre
tourné dans une situation d instantanés
regardant l'émission instantanée ici il
faut prendre des décisions tout de suite
même si c'est pas la loi alors moi je
préfère réfléchir je dis très
franchement mais qu'on se souvient juste
j'aime réfléchir avant de décider très
bien j'espère que
ce que vous avez dit sur le personnel
dans les sièges est solide et ce n'est
pas non je vais arrêter c'était de les
prochaines marge de manoeuvre la dignité
nos intentions gens qui nous écoutent
réussir chez ces aménagements jamais
également oui et qui des fois on ne
peuvent pas se faire charger parce que
les préposés ont vu les gens s'attendent
je répétais ça que lorsqu'on aura les
marges de manoeuvre c'est l'endroit où
on va mettre des sous soins à domicile
les années ans et celle ci est celle de
la santé mentale on n'a pas parlé de
santé mentale aujourd'hui mais c'est
également remboursé s'il ya plein de
sujets qu'on aurait pu et je criais
remercie de vous êtes prêté à l'exercice
on reprendre seul les remercie tout le
monde peut participer j'ai beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup apprécié et puis on vous à
votre personnel donnera sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est énorme messieurs dames
merci à la maison merci d'avoir été là
pour cette émission trop courte la
prochaine fois je vous promets ont fait
une heure et demie au moins il y avait
énormément de questions
merci de votre attention sur toulouse
demain comme d'habitude 15h au revoir à
la prochaine